so we just discussed the January 6
hearings where some bombshell new
information were revealed or was
revealed Trump being supportive of the
rioters who wanted to kill Mike Pence
they wanted to hang Mike Pence and Trump
supported that clear evidence showing
that Trump was being repeatedly told by
people around him uh that his election
claims were false and much more so even
before these hearings just the fact that
they were happening enraged Trump but
then of course afterwards he was not too
happy and before we take a look at what
he said the scary part about all this is
if you watch the hearings it was made so
clear something we already knew but it
was made really clear in these hearings
that all of this was motivated by Trump
and the people perpetuating his same
lies
people said after the fact who were
arrested the ones who had broken into
the capital I did this because president
Trump told me to
let's take a quick look at that you made
me want to come was the fact that
you know I had supported Trump all that
time I did believe you know that the
election was being stolen
um and Trump asked us to come he
personally asked for us to come to DC
that day and I thought for everything
he's done for us if this is the only
thing he's going to ask of me and then
people are reading his tweets while
they're breaking into the capital
facts
they were previously certified U.S
demands so all of this was caused by him
telling these lies and as was revealed
he was told by people close to him that
what he was saying was not true that
there was no evidence for the claims he
was making but yet he kept going out and
lying
and still and
the craziest part too is that we're a
year and a half later
still no evidence of the claims he's
made and yet he's still going off about
the election being stolen and before the
hearings happened as well as after the
hearings happened with all these
Revelations that came out his only
response to all of it is to keep telling
those lies
he took through social saying
and this is before the hearings the on
select committee didn't spend one minute
studying the reason that people went to
Washington DC in massive numbers far
greater than the fake news media is
willing to report
so obsessed with that or that the
unselects are willing to even mention
because January 6 was not simply a
protest it represents the greatest
movement in the history of our country
to make America great again it was about
an election that was rigged and stolen
random capitalizations for no reason and
a country that was about to go to hell
and look at our country now and he puts
out another truth saying the onslite
committee of political thugs essentially
the same group brought you the fully
debunked and discredited Russia Russia
Russia hoax and many others refused to
study and report and aniani goes to make
the exact same point and then we'll skip
to after the hearings happened so the
unselect committee of political hacks
refused to play any of the many positive
Witnesses and statements refuses to talk
of the election fraud and irregularities
that took place on a massive scale and
decided to use a documentary maker from
fake news ABC to spin only negative
footage our country is in such trouble
well I could not agree with that last
statement more our country is in a lot
of trouble but for the opposite reasons
that he would think so what he's doing
is so scary because we're a year and a
half
out
and watching everything that has
happened all the damage that's been
caused by his lies his only response to
all of that is to keep telling his lies
so what he's doing is setting up a
situation where the exact same thing
could happen again
this is a massive threat to our
democracy
and
while I totally recognize the Democrats
have so many issues
and we should Point those out criticize
them
what they will do and what we know that
Biden would do if he lost the next
election is concede and give up power
and that is what holds our democracy
together and so while I know a lot of
people on the right think this statement
comes off as hyperbolic
it's true Donald Trump is the biggest
threat right now to American democracy
again I know a lot of right-wingers hear
that they're like oh my God some Lefty
but really think about it in 2020 he was
okay allowing uh our democracy our
Democratic process to fail for his own
gain so that he could stay in power all
based off of Lies
he was willing to let all that happen
just for his own game
how is that not the biggest threat if
he's clearly trying to set up a
situation where he can do it again he's
telling the same lies
and so
we can't withstand Another January 6th
we can't withstand having a president in
power who refuses uh or does everything
possible to the last second to keep
himself in power even if he lost the
election we just cannot survive that as
a democracy and so
if you're on the right and you're
reasonable at all I beg you to think
about with all the issues you probably
have with the left
on this
take a stand for
democracy and the importance of having
people in power who respect automocracy
enough to want to give up power if they
lose a fair and free election
doesn't matter we can figure out our
disagreements later but as of now we
should unite conservatives and liberals
and I mean the reasonable conservatives
who don't believe the election lies to
do everything we can to prevent Trump
from getting empowered so that we don't
have to go through that again
where maybe it goes worse next time
because I can tell you everything that
went wrong for Trump in 2020 that caused
Biden to eventually get in power he's
gonna be ready and not allow those
things to go wrong again so we do have
to take this seriously and everyone who
is even somewhat reasonable needs to
unite to prevent him from getting back
in power
super appreciative to the David Pacman
show for having me fill in today don't
forget to check out my channel Luke
Beasley on YouTube if you're watching on
YouTube or listening to the podcast
there will be a link in the description
box definitely go check me out we'll be
right back with much more one of our
long time sponsors is monk pack offering
delicious sweet granola bars and nut and
Seed bars with only one gram of sugar or
less two to three net carbs perfect if
you do keto and 150 calories or under so
you can enjoy a sweet satisfying crunchy
snack without the guilt their granola
bars come in flavors like peanut butter
coconut cocoa chip Honey Nut my favorite
blueberry almond vanilla monk pack nut
and Seed bars come in flavors like sea
salt dark chocolate macadamia white
chocolate caramel sea salt and pumpkin
seed cinnamon I've always found the
flavor and texture of These Bars awesome
and unique you've got to try it at least
one I think you'll be hooked and if you
don't love monk pack as much as I do
they'll refund all of your money or
exchange the product you'll also get 20
off your first order when you go to
monkpak.com and enter the code pack
minute checkout or click the link in the
description